what's up my babies it's episode 173 of
congratulations what's up dudes it's me
and chips dudes and chicks it's Chris
D'Elia for congratulations episode 173
and I'm here with trash dog right here a
lot of guys been asking about trash dog
ever since I talked about him on Rogen
and put it on my Instagram and
everything but this [ __ ] will
eat anything dude this dog right here
chen's out the trash dog will eat
[ __ ] anything as long as it crinkles
I swear to God if something goes it'll
look over and run over and eat the [ __ ]
and we found him and now he's in this
house god damn dude all right we'll
catch you later
dog shut it everywhere great he shut
everywhere is shedded a word or shed He
shed everywhere cool anyway it's episode
173 of congratulations and that was the
new theme remix from mr. green and I
really like that one that one [ __ ]
it's very lit it's very bangin it's very
pop in and it's very lit and it's fire
so and I'm and I'm [ __ ] young I can
say that kind of [ __ ] I'm nobody's I've
never seen anybody younger than me so
it's all good I used this I dude I said
that's it that's it I started using my
new [ __ ] I started wearing my shirts
not just t-shirts because I have nowhere
to go and I you know I'd normally don't
know where the nice [ __ ] when I go out
at night to go onstage or I would only
you know wear it to be [ __ ] going out
and see and seeing people but I'm not
seeing anybody now now I see more people
on my [ __ ] although I I what my
podcast reaches more people than I do
out out at night anyway but it's all
good dude and anyway it's just like the
19th the ninth episode we've done in
quarantine and it's fine I wonder what
the country is going to go back huh I
have deep deep analysis of what's going
on in the world and when it's gone when
it's gonna happen and all that [ __ ] I
don't share with you guys but I'm very
deep I'm a very deep person I don't want
you to know that I keep it to myself
because I'm a good person
I'm
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] that just goes out
there and starts talking about
everything like everybody does because
it's so goddamn annoying so what do you
think about none uh it's none of that
[ __ ] dude my mind is turning to mush I
don't deal with too many people you know
I just I deal with only the people that
I I [ __ ] like for people in my life I
don't read [ __ ] you know when this
quarantine first I was like maybe I'll
get a good book or some [ __ ]
no I just look out the window and stare
and also sometimes look at my phone and
then sometimes I just like think about
shoes so that's it but I got my whole
life ahead of me you know and my back
hurts and I work out dude and I push
through man I [ __ ] push rod to my
legs yesterday I do like that dude when
I push up I go I'd do it like a [ __ ]
like this [ __ ] dude
mmm anyway let's get it let's get into
it you know complaint g6 fine dude
cement natasha kiss fine dude - [ __ ]
Takashi six nine right he [ __ ] is
blaming everybody on he's blaming
billboard for Takashi
he's blaming Billboard for buying number
once which of course you can do that he
said six credit cards bought ariana
grande hit the the number ones that it's
it's her it's her it's that that that's
why they got the number one which of
course that happened because why the
[ __ ] wouldn't people do that people are
like it's I by the way it's not ariana
grande E's fault
it's [ __ ] billboards fault but that's
how you do it dude
as one fire said before we turn this on
the rich get richer and don't just say
blanket [ __ ] like that but he did say
that I want to find this video and I
can't find us that's great
on Takashi six nine I should probably do
this [ __ ] before I start
and bio and do it like that because I
want to do it the way I want to do it
and you guys are here for me for that
this is his Instagram
6:9 I'm back in they mad he says just
made everything up himself here we go he
talks about the [ __ ] I want the world
to know that okay so first of all he's
wearing grandma's panties on his head
so already what you're saying is not
going to be as interesting as what the
[ __ ] is on your head so that's a huge
criticism if you want people to think
you're interesting what's coming out
your mouth is interesting don't wear
grandma panties on your head okay
they're literally silk pink panties that
are just like flopped on his head
they're not even pushed back they're
just like it looks like he's the [ __ ]
the chef from the Muppets that you can
tweak and he's dressed all in white like
he shut up to paint with the grandma's
panties on his [ __ ] chef from the
muppet lost his lost his job no no chef
where's this is he's the chef from the
Muppets he's wearing all white and a
[ __ ] a hat that looks deflated it it
looks like he ran out ideas and he's got
so many [ __ ] jewelry's on and for
watches wearing a for watches because
he's too too poor to get a watch that
tells different timezones he just has
one for each time zone a guy Atlantic I
got Pacific
I got Central and I got the other one
that nobody ever talks about the one
that Phoenix does that they go halfway
to a year they go back and they halfway
a year to go the other way um I think I
commented on this I wrote for watches
yeah there it is and somebody wrote bro
who are you my that's my favorite one
you can number ones on they do it in a
more echoey room by the way six nine do
it in a more ecobee room literally did
it at [ __ ] in a lobby somewhere hey
what's up you kabob billboards that's
the rest you
by number ones on Billboard now let me
tell you what happened we have an
ongoing investigation just now legit we
was having with we was having an ongoing
investigation we was having an ongoing
investigation dude
so wouldn't get the part if he
auditioned for NYPD blue sir we've we
was having an ongoing into the
investigation why can't I ever say
investigation it's all good
this dude is [ __ ] just Rosie Perez
with face tattoos that's who he is Rosie
Perez
we was having an ongoing investigation
dude that's actually the dumbest
sentence of all time you either were
having an are having an investigation or
there's an investigation that's ongoing
you can't have had an ongoing
investigation hahaha we was having an
investigation that was going on that's
still going on just so [ __ ] it up we
must having an investigation that was
the own going to see if I could wear
panties on my head
and it turns out that on going I could
opinions on my head and I wearing
panties on my head I got four why'd you
want to know what time it is on the
Atlantic it's 3 o'clock you want to know
what time it is on the Pacific that's a
12 or wait 60,000 units last second what
the investigation we found this stop
saying investigation dude sit trying to
[ __ ] sound more legit you know with
the investigation we found this people
are just commenting on this [ __ ] oh wait
where's the [ __ ] they purchased half
of those things with six credit cards
when we asked where were those six
credit cards Winchell billboard said we
can't destroy that information
understand this they bought 30,000 and
so units with six credit cards okay we
get it he says that nine times during
this thing by the way six credit cards
six credit cards
I got grandma panties on my head six
credit cards we have we was having an
ongoing investigation six credit cards
where's the [ __ ] thing about when he
put it on when he put the ongoing
investigation he talks about the Apple
what's where's his [ __ ] stupid
Instagram there's so many goddamn
instagrams for him
Takashi's six nine goddamn [ __ ]
you know what dude I this is just I
don't understand
oh here he sending it to me complain she
six fine yeah he says that's like what
you're saying you an apple it's an apple
but also you know apples red did you see
that [ __ ] were he's like Apple is red
and what of course no tiles are apple
green but it's like saying apples it's
like you see apples red and then
somebody say apple blue six credit cards
say idiot also how is he still alive
like I don't want anybody to kill
anybody but how the [ __ ] is he still
breathin dude he snitches out here its
Twitter so I could fast-forward it the
Apple thing he says dude here we go
where's the Apple thing if you want to
explain to all the hard-working artists
out there the hard-working artists that
and it's a bizarre said that because
there's a lot of stablish artists right
now that don't get number one thing how
you did duck if there's 50 million
streams right on goober why only count
30 million right so like looking at
Apple say I'm obviously looking at -
you're red but you're not but you're
telling us is not red but you
cheating right so confusing so confusing
it's like an apple you look at it I've
read you looking at it and it's red and
then someone's saying it's not red it's
like you're cheated you got caught
red-handed you saying red so many times
just so confused
it's like Little Red Riding Hood came up
to you and said this Apple he's like you
say her apples red and Little Red Riding
Hood is like that red apple now red you
got caught red-handed wearing red wings
it's like Little Red Riding Hood where
Red Wings drive a red Ferrari with red
man in it and red Foxx and he'd say the
apples red and apples red but the red
fox like the apples not red and then you
got Co red-handed cuz you cheat in red
I'll read a book it's his favorite color
yes it's like red foxes in a vet
comfortable with you and you there and
you said apple red okay and then a red
man pop in and he say over the Apple not
red anymore
and you got caught and you and you know
the Apple read and you read a book on it
and you like you read a book on cheating
and you like you got caught red-handed
the worst analogy of all time
congratulations complain see six fine
dude the way the way it has no payoff is
amazing right Apple sometimes is most
likely read something that's always read
you know Apple is rare you know
sometimes it's green sure sometimes
there's in between an Apple could be
very you know very light green or dark
green but but most of the time we think
of Apple is red just say a [ __ ] you
know what's red Rudolph's nose just say
[ __ ] what is always red my [ __ ] um
red swollen dick was an episode of ten
minute podcast ha ha
Scimitar never gonna be running for
president but anyway complaint u6 fine
obviously he's probably dead by now i
just started talking about it but and
then snoop dogg made a warning - Takashi
six nine which is great
Snoop Dogg's ninety last time he says I
ant hey Snoop Dogg get better lighting
it for your YouTube video you've got
seven trillion dollars he literally
looks like [ __ ] one of those people
that would do uh why is he [ __ ] filmed
by one of those people in almost got
away with it but I just wanted the below
that or when I was - ik buddy or he was
illegal when I was lawyering but today
and they I got time Snoop Dogg you're 90
last time you said some I had a tire but
today I got time wow you've got to get
the [ __ ] off my line [ __ ]
mmm-hmm rat boy rat boy you really
better leave me alone I ain't the one
oh [ __ ] no way no way go on and do your
[ __ ] and get out my way [ __ ] you funky
don't hit rainbow head don't get [ __ ]
so here you [ __ ] little lead a dog
alone better leave the dog alone I'll
find you again getting too far away to
carry with the analogy better let the
dog alone better go find a cat you know
they make me unhook my leash you know me
I'd be done eating a bunch of dog food
all full you know me
someone a knock at the door and I start
barking you know I'm saying
piss on [ __ ] the side of a couch you
know I'm saying better find yourself a
cat I got so far with it I you know I
got a collar did you lose your [ __ ]
mind I got faux legs man I even got two
arms I
four legs you better not [ __ ] come
for me hey dude you're [ __ ] 60 get it
together you know I did I love it man
I [ __ ] love life you know you got
this 22 year old that's like you know
you got one Apple that's red you know
Apple will you look at it Apple is red I
mean some apples is green are you
looking at this apple red and somebody
come up to you and they're like the
Apple is not red and then Snoop Dog's
like I'm a dog don't come for the dog
don't come for the dog y'all looking for
a cat go get a cat because I'm the dog I
got faux legs I got instead of when my
arms are got paws and legs flip with the
dog talk with the dog and then nice
nothing nice [ __ ] cool Tourette's red
boy rat boy again he close closer with
the rat boy oh and then [ __ ] the
hands up for no reason oh god I would
love if somebody if like a troll like
Takashi 6-9 or these guys who are trolls
um well not even trolls guys who were
famous for kind of doing well I can see
me he makes music a kiss he does nothing
but like guys who are trolls like guys
who just want attention so bad we'll say
like Takashi 6-9 Donald Trump me know
like like these guys that [ __ ] just
are crying for attention you know the
chicks on [ __ ] in story Norse the
dudes on Instagram that are like you
know kicking back if just nobody ever
paid at I give some guy was a model you
know the male model like is a chair he's
a [ __ ] just a chair right modeling is
for chicks if you got a dude there
you're a [ __ ] prop you're the you're
the [ __ ] chair for the girl to sit on
it doesn't matter okay yeah your bone
structure is nice but you're really just
a [ __ ] chair that guy that
if he like for a guy to win did for him
to join Instagram and then have him just
be like look 0 people felt like as zero
followers or if like Donald Trump
tweeted some [ __ ] crazy fantastic
[ __ ] and nobody said [ __ ] about it or
Takashi 6:9 came out of jail and nobody
was like that rapped [ __ ] I'm
gonna kill him if nobody gave a [ __ ]
that would be so detrimental to that
[ __ ]
but we can't we can't not look at it we
have to look at it because that's the
[ __ ] train wreck that's happening you
rubber net you like huh you got to look
at it it's like when the Apple is red
you know it's just such a [ __ ] it's a
bummer it's so [ __ ] funny man I
[ __ ] god I was watching this show
married at first sight it's on Netflix I
don't know if it's a Netflix original or
what but it's a show where these guys
these guys and girls meet in a [ __ ]
meet with these like people who are what
what do they like their like hitch
like what's Will Smith tech things like
we tries to get people like soul mates
and [ __ ] and they agree these people
these men and women who go to the to do
the show they go into like this room
there's like 40 of them and they the the
people the host of the TV show you
interview everyone and then find four of
them matches like the four men they
choose four men and then match them with
four women that they've interviewed and
then so they ask them everything they're
like what race would you want to be with
and the people are straight up just like
a white dude it's just like I want the
girl to be white and some there ask some
black dude is like would you like to be
what kind of religion he was like um
Christian and they're like well so what
about Jewish no not Jewish
okay what about Mormon that's kind of
Chris that's you know they believe in
Jesus no Christian
no like just hardcore hardcore you know
there's a virgin a girl that's 27 and a
virgin and they just ask and they're
like well we're gonna pay you and they
get somebody to pair them up with and
then in two weeks they say okay you're
gonna be married to this you're gonna
we've found you that we found you a
soulmate which is like absolutely
[ __ ] insane course Jeanette I mean
and but but but they they're like so
they go so here's the thing if I was in
that show first of all any guy that
would go on that show is just uh it's
it's just you're not you're not good get
it I mean you don't get it because just
don't do that I get why a girl would be
on that show because girls want it so
bad you know what I mean they just want
that [ __ ] life and the family and
[ __ ] they want it so bad but the guys
who do that show are they I don't
understand what's going on in their head
compared me there's like 27 year old
guys like there's one guy that's a
basketball player that's 66 six foot
nine and he's like a good-looking dude
and he's like I'm gonna go on this and
they blindly say okay I'll marry a
person that you the TV show host the
matchmaker says I'll marry so then they
like they you interview them and they go
and they talk to each other the host and
they're like well this person would
match with this person this one match
and they walk to the [ __ ] and then they
go to the guy and they're like hey guess
what we've got somebody for you to marry
and then the guy goes like this oh no
I'm gonna get married
hey guy dude ah I got the only thing
that you could say to that is ha
how are you happy about that II don't
know who she is and you don't know what
she looks like
what if all of a sudden she's like
you're hanging out and everything's all
good and [ __ ] and then she's over yeah
that's cool but you know [ __ ] Jews like
whoa whoa you didn't ask him about you
didn't you didn't [ __ ] ask him about
that
you didn't interview about that so how
do you feel about Jews you know that's
just so insane to me that a guy in his
20s any guy in their 20s would do
married at first sight
and then they get married I didn't watch
the end of it obviously cuz sucks but
like dude they get married in two weeks
and they call their parents are like mom
dad guess what I'm getting married and
the parents are like wow they're like
yep and I'm gonna meet them when you do
and the dads like okay well you know
yours
okay I don't know but your are you crazy
but that's okay are you kidding me dude
if I had a [ __ ] kid that wanted to be
on married at first sight I go like this
hey oh dude enjoy your life injure your
[ __ ] life do you know why I failed
and not only is this the last time I'm
gonna see you as I said I'm gonna see me
to cousin jump enough bridge because it
failed I failed in the most important
thing that's so insane dude one girl
came up and they're like guess what we
found you a husband and the girl goes
like this
oh she starts crying hey it's not real
hey dude this is as close to nothing as
you can get it's literally as close to
nothing as you can get it didn't happen
nothing happened all that happened was
somebody that knows you met somebody
else that's what happened somebody that
knows you met somebody that's like me
meeting [ __ ] Renee and say hey man
Renee is cool man you're a good guy oh
[ __ ] hey what's what's up okay oh cool
hey Kate Kate you'd like my friend Renee
I'm gonna go tell Renee that you like it
hey Renee Kate would like you and Kate
yeah okay okay oh okay you guys want to
get married
hey man no are you out of your [ __ ]
mind but this show is
okay but they're gonna get married all
that happened was it's just so [ __ ]
and people are watching this [ __ ] these
people are people are watching this [ __ ]
married at first sight couples some and
some of it works that's the most
important and are now together and have
kids dude imagine you were a baby from a
[ __ ] a you know mom and dad met each
other at the wedding what mom and dad
met each other at the wedding
what do you mean surely you knew each
other and data for a while no no no no
we met we met at the wedding
oh you guys are pieces of [ __ ] you got
that all wrong look at this [ __ ]
Meredith Forsyte star Jason carrion is
engaged after February yeah no [ __ ] they
split married at first sight dude wow
this guy there's a virgin on the show
imagine you didn't know you'd know what
you signed up for a virgin there's a
version of the show that we found him we
found a match and then she's and then
you say yeah okay here she is and then
like during the honeymoon she's like I'm
a virgin I'm like oh [ __ ] insane man at
first sight oops
ma ffs right at first sight I got to do
ads here but at Connie and Jonathan's
emotions are running high as they
prepare to say their final goodbyes
about Jonathan Jo and II th en Jonathan
no wonder he's [ __ ] looking for a wife
you smell it how
you actually leaving me yeah this is it
I it's bittersweet leg pain you know I
didn't think this day would come that
would be at the very end I'm just like
you know how much we've done together
from the good times to the bad times
like reflecting on the whole thing's
kind of gets me a little choked up till
the big day I'm happy I went through
this experience with Connie I couldn't
imagine doing with anyone else
doesn't feel real I I mean they're
splitting happenes like this even the
last I was gonna come couldn't even
believe this day was coming never
thought it would come you didn't dude
Jonathan oh you didn't think that day
would come he Yeti it um anyway sad
state of affairs here alright blue apron
I just say blue apron for dinner and
it's so good dude I had a some pasta
with some Brazil in it and oh man they
don't miss dude you ever eat a meal so
good you feel like you could eat it
again and again and never get tired of
it it's kind of like having to go to
order at a restaurant it's just great
every time when you find a dish you love
you can't wait to enjoy it again so blue
aprons kickin off somewhere with a
can't-miss menu of their top rated
recipes all through June really the
entire menu are the recipes customers
repeatedly asked to bring back the ones
they rate the highest the ones they say
they cook every week so if you're
looking to try a meal kit service this
is the perfect time to see why people
love blue apron home cooking matters now
more than ever with blue apron you can
have peace of mind by getting fresh
quality ingredients delivered straight
to your door so you can cook delicious
easy meals in the comfort of home blue
apron takes the guesswork out of dinner
and we mean more than just deciding what
to eat you can now know your ingredients
are being prepared and packaged with the
highest attention to quality and safety
and with their commitment to
transparency and reducing waste blue
apron has your back in more ways than
one
it's like your kitchen coach blue apron
I you try new things learn new skills
change up your routine fettuccine pasta
and mushrooms that's the one
that I've had recently and it's so good
chicken and brown rice lettuce cups
meatballs and harissa tomato sauce are
you kidding me my mouth is watering just
saying don't sacrifice flavor
don't settle for boring meals with blue
apron you can enjoy top-rated recipes
all month long check out this week's
menu and get $30 off across your first
two deliveries when you visit blue apron
com / Congrats that's blue apron com /
Congrats blue apron feed your soul
that's good for now yeah alright uh I
got two more later I don't know that
dude I got on tick-tock your boy got on
tick-tock I've been on tick-tock but I'm
going full cylinders on tick-tock I make
killer tick tocks dude tic tacs [ __ ]
man I don't have talked about this
before but I realized I realized I did a
tick-tock recently about I found out
this new thing that that tick tock is
this new thing about tick tock is
there's a POV section where these people
act to the camera and they have a music
they have music playing and they're
acting like they met a girl and then
like something and then like the girl
says they'll go out with them and then
the guy smiles all cute and [ __ ] but
guys do this [ __ ] and I didn't
understand quite really what was
happening with this tick tock [ __ ] I
didn't understand like I didn't
understand who was like watching this
[ __ ] like it'll play this [ __ ] like this
guy does this guy what's his name
Devon K Hurley is one of my favorites
he'll he'll do you do only POV ones and
it'll say it'll be like part it'll be
like twelve parts and it'll be like him
meeting a girl they're all 15 seconds
long like this is part 10 she comes over
to see if my brother's home
no because your brother home no he's not
and they just gone now he should be
coming home soon I'll wait for him
that's it that's all that happens
she walks in it says it's a guy's face
she walks in he's your brother home and
then he goes and it says no she's not
you have to read it and then he he
should be coming home and then she says
I'll wait for him and it's only a
picture of this guy's face and I'm like
40 like que unit I mean I'm like 40 and
I'm like que but then I'm like why is
this a good thing and why is this part
10 and then it goes up to there's part
12 you decide to stay over and when you
wake up you see me getting ready for the
day this one's two seconds and this has
a hundred and eighty-nine thousand views
and he just puts on his shirt and he
just goes why is a hundred and
eighty-nine people watching this
thousand people watching this was a
hundred be watching why am i watching it
and I'm like who is watching this [ __ ]
and then I look at the comments and I
get it some somebody comments it this
guy that the owner of the account says
tag a friend alright somebody writes
okay but imagine actually actually
waking up to that I'd be dead somebody
else comments Oh
if somebody writes I'm kind of loving
these POVs keep it up and then he
responds good god it's weird dude people
get in you're like hahaha
this other one who's Loki blushing a
little right now but I realize these
people who are commenting their five
like they're for real learning to type I
I just imagined that that people my age
were watching this [ __ ] cuz I'm my age
therefore everybody's my age because I'm
conceited or whatever the [ __ ]
self-centered and I realized that
everyone was five when I posted mine I
wrote me when I meet my boyfriend and
tell him I love him and then he [ __ ]
dies and I put I put it to this song and
then I wrote I write I love you I say it
says the week and then I said oh you
love me too nice and then I go a crazy
look and I said oh [ __ ] you fell off a
cliff and a grab for him
that's my peel dude and I did that for
me so I could laugh at it and some
people are like relatable this happened
to my dad sending prayers away of course
they're joking somewhat more POVs this
is you're calling a joke obviously then
people are commenting on other [ __ ] I
can't look at you the same after you the
show of course cuz I played child
molester somebody wrote no 50 no please
50 no which is a reference to this
podcast
and then somebody writes something like
man this is actually really sad and I'm
like oh I'm like but what no oh man this
is actually really sad no it's not you
first of all you don't meet somebody and
right away say I love you in them they
fall off a cliff how is that sad and
it's because you're five and that's when
I realized that this tick tock [ __ ]
so I got on tick tock cuz man
[ __ ] Jessica Alba and like 50
cent Iran ticked I don't know 50 cent is
and [ __ ] but like people are loved and
tick tock it's so funny that like [ __ ]
you know J Lo's on tick tock but da man
some of these are so I followed this one
account pov what is it POV there's just
great look what I what hype oh yeah hype
house is what it is
these dudes who do it
I accidentally walk in while you're
changing at a party
I mean this will never happen this guy
walks in this guy walks in hello sorry I
walked in on you and he goes to walk
away and she's and then it goes hey wait
stay yeah really
okay cool and they all have that [ __ ]
hair dude that's like so quaffed over
their [ __ ] eyes you know just looks
like a big-ass ducks tail ah [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude if my kid grows up to do some
[ __ ] [ __ ] like that and has that
big-ass duck
[ __ ] [ __ ] in front of the head
with his [ __ ] duck ass quaff dude I
go like this cut it or you're not
leaving dude when Dad gets mad at your
hair and says you can't leave unless you
cut it and then these [ __ ] chicks who
are 11 or they're you know the [ __ ]
16 and they're just trying to act like
they're on tick tock for fun but they're
really trying to be sexy and they're way
too old for they're way too young to be
[ __ ] doing the [ __ ] and then creeps
likes 50-year old men are watching them
goddamn it what's the one that [ __ ]
the cartoon character one was good to
the TechTalk the cartoon character one
there were like if I was a cartoon
character what would I be what if I was
a cartoon character look every day who's
this Jess implements summer camp at
least this girl's got clothes on she's
cool but there's chicks that are just
like it'll be like going skiing outfit
and it's just like a chick with silver
dollars over her nipples and and like a
[ __ ] and earmuffs and you're like
going skiing on a [ __ ] mountain of
[ __ ] did I used to have a [ __ ]
Japanese Spanish teacher in in high
school and you would and his name was
mr. TECA made it
okay muchacho okay muchachos he would
always say that okay muchachos okay
naturally opener I've done that put it
I'll a Mamie Chuck muchacha little Tic
Tacs [ __ ] sucks dude
I gotta get on I gotta get on anymore I
want to do another one tonight do it I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna have the illest
Tech Talk dude there's people who have
[ __ ] 30 million followers and [ __ ] on
tick tock I'm 40 man I should be [ __ ]
20 I should be 20 I should start being
20 I'm 20 I identify as a 20 year old
[ __ ] you dude oh dude
also Hawthorne new ads dude but this
[ __ ] Hawthorne are you still wearing the
same Hugo Boss Cologne you got in high
school you have you loser
who do you wear Cologne dude huh
we got cool water Hawthorne I went
online took the quiz I did this - I know
you're like you didn't do it I did do it
I took the quiz it was really cool mix
of trying to figure out what things I
like along with the personality
questions that give me a unique mix of
products that are good for me alright I
did I sat down with one fire and I did
it smells great
the whole thing is personalized a
convenient this stuff showed up
Hawthorne uses premium quality and
breezes super easy to buy online
luxurious packaging the whole thing is
really cool and now I feel like I have a
nice stuff I look at my shower I got the
face scrub I got the bar soap that's big
they don't skimp out on it - and shampoo
and I use it dude you take a quick
two-minute
quiz and Hawthorne tells you the two
colognes that are best for you you work
one for work and one for play and it's
totally risk-free with shipping and free
returns but it's it's it's awesome and
it smells great and I do the deodorant
I use it all man I walk out the door
smellin like Hawthorne man father's Day
is coming up
there you go check out Hawthorne at
Hawthorne dot see oh that's Hawthorne
with Annie and use my promo code
congrats to get 10% off your first /
that's H aw th o RN e dot co and use my
code congrats to get 10% off your
purchase Hawthorne dot Co Bambi when
running a business HR issues can kill
you wrongful termination suits minimum
wage requirements labor regulations and
HR manager salaries aren't cheap an
average of seventy thousand dollars a
year lot Bambi's spelled ba MBE e was
created specifically for small
businesses you can get a dedicated HR
manager craft HR policy and maintain
your compliance all for just $99 a month
if I were to hear that I would be like
well that's gotta cost 75 million
dollars each week but it doesn't ninety
nine dollars a month you dedicated with
Bambi you can change HR for your biggest
liability to your biggest strength your
dedicated HR manager is available by
phone email or real-time chat
month-to-month no hidden fees cancel
anytime
let Bambi help get your free HR audit
today go to Bambi comm / congrats right
now to schedule your free HR audit
that's Bambi calm / congrats spelled ba
MBE e-comm / Congrats
but yeah man I don't know I don't know
what's wrong with the you I want to know
what's going on every generation is like
a day youth what's going on with the
youth but this tick-tock thing now it's
even more apparent with them it's more
apparent than ever because of the the
Internet I mean dude this girl did a
tick-tock that was like you get pulled
oh I get pulled over with my black
boyfriend and then he get he gets shot
because he's black did but I don't know
where it is you know it you know it I'm
gonna play it he's gonna send it to me
one fires gonna send it to me in the
notes and but yeah the she did it was a
POV one and it was the most thing of all
time this is actually a very interesting
thing to talk about now because uh this
is something that I first saw and I'm
gonna play it for you guys and this is
something I first saw and it's it and
when I first saw it I thought oh
everything is [ __ ] there's nothing
like did I thought it was the worst
thing I ever saw online every
my life like ever in my life I never saw
a worse thing oh my life do you have it
or getting it I ice texted it to you
guys oh it's probably on a link I texted
it to you guys
no but it's it's it's way back you
saying and I'm pissed
one fire at the ready at the ready
I'm finding it it is way back we text so
much like [ __ ] fools let me find it
there's my tick-tock that I did that was
beautiful
where is it is it this far back come on
dude alright here we are we thought we
got it we took it took a small break to
find that and now I got it
this is they posted it the the vibe for
Billy formerly known as Julian posted on
Twitter although it's not his original
video it's this girl I'm gonna actually
leave her name out of it oh wait no was
on POV hi-pass never mind which is the
best on tick-tock but this chick posted
it it says me and my boyfriend in quote
or in parenthesis who's black get pulled
over he goes to touch my face after I
tell him that I love him then the police
officer shoots him so she plays us
and then she goes oh my god like he gets
shot
what the [ __ ] like that now at first
when I saw this I thought oh man this is
horrible and then I found a video of
this girl who's like an apology video
and she's like I just want everyone to
know that I mean it's like she's like
twelve twelve and it's like the cutest
thing she's just like I'm really sorry I
didn't mean to offend anyone and I'm
like this poor [ __ ] girl like she
doesn't know dude let me tell you
something man I didn't know I wasn't
mature until 30 [ __ ] 15 until I was
thirty fifteen okay for real though
until I was like early 30s I would do
dumb as [ __ ] [ __ ]
this girl's like 14 doing this and of
course I couldn't tell cuz I was just
watching it nobody looks 14 anymore that
those days are well or long gone
you ever see a [ __ ] 14-year old she
looks 30 I've never said there's no such
thing as a fourteen-year-old girl
anymore they go from like 6 to 25 and
and this girl she apologized and I was
like my heart broke for her because
everyone is like on Twitter piling on
before wipe you know just are you really
out there what do you people are [ __ ]
it's just I hate tick tock this made me
laugh
what Oh God everyone's I will never cut
you'll never catch me with a white girl
kind of [ __ ] anyway they dragged her I
can't remind them but they dragged her
but this chick was 12 and so I saw this
apology video and I was like oh [ __ ] I
jumped to a conclusion thinking like
this idiot and like it's my bad because
this girl's [ __ ] however old she is
she was like I'm so sorry I had just
read a book and I was trying to be
socially aware and I didn't realize that
I wasn't trying to do it for a following
I was trying to do it to like get the
awareness out there and I realized how
it looked now like this girl is like
legitimately learning this lesson for
the first time on a grand scale and
that's sad and I've been and I feel for
this [ __ ] child because she gets
piled on now granted it's like I saw a
tweet the other day person gets canceled
because something that they said when
they were 16 it's like dude I was 32
saying dumb [ __ ] for real I mean dude if
you go and look at old videos of [ __ ] of
people that would get canceled I was
just looking at an interview from Peter
Peter Sellers one of my favorite actors
ever and there was like he was doing
like a was he doing like a a Chinese
voice been [ __ ] cancelled just came
on all of a sudden
[Music]
[Laughter]
resist and so sorry he's doing like that
[ __ ] he's doing a typical Asian thing
and if like somebody did that now if
Will Smith that was just like hey today
and that's so neat guy he was like I
hope I get this how old how do I get the
disdain hold on you'd be like all right
that's it Will Smith SIA the [ __ ] are
anyway Peter Sellers is cancelled and
it's fine cuz he's dead dude cancel me
when I'm dead dude I got a tummy ache
it's fine I have a stomach ache because
I keep eating scones
dude I delivered [ __ ] cookies to
Hilary Duff
there's your part two on that I deliver
cookies to Hilary Duff delivered scones
got her son a book about sharks and got
her daughter another thing I can't
remember
Cookie Monster stuff because that's what
I am because their neighbor is a [ __ ]
Cookie Monster cuz they ate their
cookies and I gave it to him and I
dropped him off and I didn't want to do
it I mean I did want to do it but I
didn't want to person to drop it off I
wanted someone else to do it and my girl
was like just drop it off and yourself
and I was like fine and I got there and
when I got there I haven't met her
husband yet but I got there and I was
blocking their driveway and I was going
to just drop it off in front of the
thing and the husband pulls and I was
like oh hey sorry block aye I'm sure you
heard but I ate your cookies I said and
he was like yeah I get it yeah it's all
good I was like so I'm just dropping
this off for anyway and then she walks
up with her daughter they were on a walk
and I think aha
you're all here okay and in my head I'm
like that [ __ ] [ __ ] my girl made
me do this [ __ ] I was gonna not wear a
shirt dude I was gonna not worry sure I
was gonna go do it and not wear a shirt
I was gonna be like I'm just gonna top
this off real quick no show kids a [ __ ]
I didn't have a shirt on to quarantine
[ __ ] 40 year old hey guys here's
cookies in a shark book they're here the
daughter was there mommy was over there
man
that's an [ __ ] come on Jesus Christ
they ate the scones they're [ __ ] warm
dude I'll make you warm scones man if
anyway dude my mail if you get it that
your mail that's the [ __ ] law this
story and I have a stomachache none of
pretty sure it's because the [ __ ]
scones I ate a scone we didn't give them
all the scones
that would've been [ __ ] dude if I'm
making scones I'm eating some of them
and have a stomachache now because the
[ __ ] scones so if you have a
stomachache I'm sorry Hilary Duff dude
we got we raised sick $15,000 for
feeding America by selling those masks
we sell sold those masks the life rips
mats and the silly just goose time mass
and the future too bright mask we sold
them all the profits on the masks went
to feeding America and we raised 15 that
we all all of us together who bought the
masks we raised $15,000 for feeding
America and that's awesome and it feels
so good to friggin help and you guys
that's awesome and life rips and now for
feeding America life reps and maybe we
were able to feed more of America that
wouldn't be fed because [ __ ] life
reps dude and that's so dope nah nothing
maybe the first one so that's it I told
you I've been my restless leg syndrome I
got to catch it dude I got to catch it
when I catch it is the main thing I got
to catch it
this is how freakin much of a guy I am
I have restless leg syndrome I finally
figured out after like six or seven
years of having restless legs that the
only thing that cures it and this is not
a joke is having an orgasm that's the
only thing that cures it okay it's the
only thing that cores it now I don't
want to be talking about this because I
don't like talking about jerking off and
stuff like that unless it's in my comedy
act okay unless I'm making jokes this
isn't a joke having an orgasm is the
only thing that helps my restless leg
syndrome
I know my family sometimes this is
podcast I'm sorry but it's the truth
okay now I don't masturbate that much I
just don't I don't I never really have
it hasn't been my thing it always feels
kind of weird to me nobody's around and
I'm just you know but I will say when I
have sex and I have an orgasm I'm very
quiet but I am really dramatic and loud
when I'm by myself
masturbating have an orgasm that's when
I really pop off oh yeah that's me by
myself alright but when I'm quiet it's
like I'm trying to [ __ ] rob a bank
like after hours
dipping through the lasers so I found
out that one time I'd a loss I was like
you know my legs were going nuts and I
was like I forget I guess I'll just do
this pass some time I did it and then
immediately did it again the next night
perchance immediately passed out
you know this I've talked about this
okay now it's become my kind of like my
nightly thing but here's the thing okay
I don't want to be jerking off this is
how much of a guy I am I'm in bed trying
to go to sleep I can't fall asleep and
I'm almost asleep but my legs are
buzzing and I'm like come on man just
please fall asleep I don't want to have
to wake up a jerk-off like
straight up and then I'm like I guess I
have to cuz I just can't I just can't
fall asleep and then when I wake up to
do it I gotta get you know I want it to
be quick so I'm not gonna use my
imagination because men are visual so I
start watching porn and I try to do it
as quick as possible and then I'll do it
and then once I'm done I'm so tired and
I just started watching porn more and
I'm not even into it genuinely because
the things that take me out are the
titles of the porns like you got me
thinking about it oh it got me thinking
about the one last time when I said suck
me off the completion like when they all
make it grand you know like every here's
what title every porn should be [ __ ]
or suckin or riding or eatin you know ii
mean why is it eating you know you're
not swallowing it you're not chewing it
[Music]
so gross you know this is the After
Hours is wise at the end of the podcast
but the way there porns title is just so
[ __ ] dumb dude all of them like this
these are like adults uploading these
and making the titles petite teenager
gets horny for a big [ __ ] you know like
a 45 year old wrote that here's another
one bodybuilder stud has his way with
this petite teen spinner so [ __ ]
disrespectful teen spinner I mean dude
ah this one hot big boobs brunette peed
herself after
hot sex and full-load cream pie so many
different titles in one that's the
transformer of titles hot big boobs
brunette Peter self transformers hot sex
and full load cream pie rollout I was by
day on uh this is my porn hot big boobs
brunette peeing transformers rollout hot
sex and full load cream pie
too many it should just be [ __ ] dude
big boobs were met peeing or self Oh hot
sex full load cream pie oh yeah it's a
childish here's another one big ass teen
big ass teen almost caught [ __ ] at
the mall risky public sex dude I love
how it's it's so crass and simple but
also they'll add a little flavor tool I
can get descriptive you know what I mean
it'll be like big boobs [ __ ] at a
wonderful water park big boobs [ __ ] had
a wonderful waterpark here here's
another one here anytime views
interracial it's like what do you would
we scientists curly-haired [ __ ] filled
up multiple times by interracial dick
like gets so [ __ ] you know get so
[ __ ] what do you call it specific and
then the cartoon hey who's watching the
Family Guy porn what [ __ ] straight up
loser in sell his idea Peter Griffin
[ __ ] Louis yeah yeah as he's busting a
nut
[Laughter]
I don't understand look at this two
[ __ ] one mouth [ __ ] [ __ ] a young
cheerleader swallowed double come got
all the key words there huh God do it
anytime they're just so crass when they
use the word like drilled not drilled
you know the step brother step son step
mom [ __ ] is just oh here's my favorite
one Wow look at this one it's called
true anal like that [ __ ] that like that
would be a [ __ ] on HBO true anal
tonight at 8 billion alone barrel what's
the [ __ ] what's that [ __ ] HBO
theme boom see what's the old one though
Dan that ain't alone it wasn't that what
it was true anal HBO feature
presentation true anal followed by Basic
Instinct here we go what is this [ __ ]
oh they had like a whole thing I forgot
about this
I forgot about this they'd zoom over the
city 1983 opening credits boy they got
rid of this [ __ ] nobody is a [ __ ] about
this that's hilarious so long here it is
true true anal
tonight at 8:00 dude
good
body builders stud has his way with this
petite teen spinner tonight at eight hot
big boobs
brunette peed herself after a hot sex
and full load
[Music]
wow man wow that's [ __ ] funny dude
Wow
dude I could do that all day long
Wow I'll do more it's my podcast
[ __ ] you here we go dude here's more I'm
just reading porn titles doing the HBO
during the HBO
[Music]
hippie team caught trespassing bucks
security
beautiful girlfriend can't swallow
enough company so cosplayer cougar
Shonda fake [ __ ] by pink and body guy
milk step up seduces team daughter best
morning hand job from young hot
girlfriend with big [ __ ] shot mini boom
mini boom
not a boom if its many booms our big
dude wow dude
I'll do more [ __ ] you dude my podcast 21
sec stream I'll call you later my step
granddaughter needs me
she pulls him back to come inside
[ __ ] aussi couple
Wow dude this is the best the podcast
has ever been big tits
chubby team gangbang and DP tonight at
eight Chinese couples with high physical
quality have a sex in swimming pool dude
are you kidding me that's a real one
nenenene name isn't prison are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] me
oh my god dude it's the best a podcast
has ever been there we go dude not to
read this one again
[Music]
Chinese couples with high physical
quality have a sex in swim sex hold on
hold on I like to do
[Music]
Chinese couples with high physical
quality have a sex in swimming pool ex
chimera
young mistress passionate sex with her
slave let's do it
feeling of a Rory's school by birth
massage parlor shaped and [ __ ] [ __ ]
- or what is [ __ ] pin a sh a student's
18 years old kinda lean on that sterling
guns unless the gun cunning thought oh
man I got to the [ __ ] Asian version
there's foursome what the [ __ ] is that
dude anyway it's so funny when they do
this [ __ ] blonde with amazing looks give
her feet different work what god damn
dude porn is just knows no bounds ah
[ __ ] young Jesus Christ sees titles dude
I'll do [ __ ] more hot blonde milf
Aaliyah
sucks [ __ ] and talks like a filthy [ __ ]
face for young girl satisfied in the
truck
sailor Lewin [ __ ] by monsters then lay
egg is that housefly wait a minute what
that's a real one sailor moon' [ __ ] by
monsters then lay egg is that housefly
[Music]
hey children exist
sailor moon [ __ ] by monsters then lay
egg is that a housefly yo what the [ __ ]
Israel oh this is even older dude wow
this one's even older dude
[Music]
this is amazing dude all right do it I
mean you know how long much how much
long how much longer can we do this more
[ __ ] more dude it's my podcast [ __ ]
you I'll do more I'll do more there's
one just called good head it gave up
cold husband watches his wife get [ __ ]
by a stranger v-day gift
[Music]
[ __ ] HBO was around in 1912 Jesus
these are old luster resubmission for
forty Simona and Leo love their way
stepdaughter Alexa Nova shocks her
stepdad rot anymore with her ass how
exhibitionist girl shows boobs and [ __ ]
at the beach multiple orgasm horny milk
cowgirl writing bet you wish your
girlfriend would do this public agent
[ __ ] blonde Jordan prices massive tits
I almost passed out right there reading
a bunch of these is the move dude
[Music]
here we go more here we go more and then
and then I'm done
horny schoolgirl deep throat and come in
mouth POV after college vixen she's
always fantasized about having sex with
a stranger pantyhose encasement European
escort removed a condom so I just had to
come in as bbw thick gloves [ __ ] BB
co2 little schoolgirl [ __ ] suck after
school lick sonic Barbara and Rosa small
tits hog April Anderson has anal orgasm
impossible loser fruit jerk-off Jude Wow
and never get in a Disney movie but it's
all good do it you come to this [ __ ]
podcast for the realness dude porn
titles read from HBO [ __ ] goddamn
dude thank God we found that thank God
we found that dude dude cosplay [ __ ]
is the weirdest I just I want to [ __ ]
you as you dude I don't want you to be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] ginger Platt or whatever
from the [ __ ] goddamn cartoon you
know I want you to be you I don't want
to be having sex with you and you have
purple hair and I'm like who are you you
know I want to have sex with you 4 p.m.
alright I'm done dude [ __ ] man wow what
a good [ __ ] mood I'm in alright
thanks guys listen you can text me watch
my special on Netflix it's called no
pain you can text me or whatever have to
you can go to my Instagram and then find
my [ __ ] on you can text me from the
homepage actually text me and you can
also follow me on tip top talk that's
I'm soaked I'm 40 and that's it man
tweet me good [ __ ] funny porn titles
all right you guys thanks a lot hey dog
hey if I tried dog by everybody
[Music]
okay